[Music]
speed-dating it's awkward it's weird and
you will a decided let's make it even
more awkward and weird today we're
watching 20 versus one speed-dating guys
this girl is going to speed eight guys
in front of her yeah I'm confused no I'm
here for no other reason
great question alright she's excited not
to continue this pattern of very very
bad men so she has history with bad men
now she's gonna meet 20 is she gonna
find the right one
I'm excited okay so they're all in a
group chain and they're all sitting in
front of her then watch step on her
dating standards to good taste
what's the point she's right there we
totally live in a society everyone is
stuck on their phones guys this is crazy
would you guys think this
bunch of sins disgusting
someone lazy
nice legends very nice respect never
date a woman ever that's gay I love to
dance
so I don't like it when I'm with
somebody who's a total debbie downer or
boring and just kind of stands there and
doesn't want to dance she likes to party
and drink a lot and for that reason I'm
out
not that I was in to begin with but I'm
definitely out we're at the club or bar
and you're the type to not dance and
just stand there
what please go stand somewhere outside
of this separate dam only one dude is
like not like this I ain't dancing with
this I'm doing it I like how she
looks personally insulted by it that
makes it all the better I don't know why
I'm so like no one's gonna date you I
would definitely want someone
open-minded but not a freak so you
shouldn't be in two feet wait what are
these conversations I don't agree with
DJ Kali
why you know a little choking fun Oh
choking I think anyone like feet
you like sucking on some toes stay in
the circle otherwise feet are great I
love chicken feet about choking
[Laughter]
[Music]
if you're not open to choking please
don't more feet choking the feet is that
what we're talking about I could do that
I want you to crush my esophagus a
little gently choking I want you to
crush my throat
gentle choking is ok I want you to crush
it no one no one I do like him tall
because I'm pretty tall for an Asian
girl and when I put on my heels
I would like to still be shorter than my
man so they need to be it when I put on
the fit in this fictional height this
fall's height I still want you to be
tall enemy that standards the young guy
see what she doesn't know he put on high
heels as well
yeah I'm still taller what's your
problem oh no it's happening no snaps
mr. really about to give this short
homies another L I love you boys
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah you don't need a a tornado the
texting thing is surprisingly funny for
love it I kind of selfie to talk about
that I'm only willing to share your love
win a pet you can win a pet with Wow but
how do you guys feel about kids I love
kids I've been in on since I was 10 so
I'm like a natural around babies and
kids but I want to really just share a
love with somebody that's I don't know
why I say as a kid I feel like I would
be afraid of her it's all about loving
each other before we can you know bring
somebody else in the world I think you
should be mentally stable as well
financially stable because you're gonna
be responsible for shaping their future
it's kind of a big pressure because you
could really somebody up in the
head you're not there and I what the
hell was she talking about I'm not there
in the head I guess I'm a help
I'm already out long ago was never tame
I love that I love that look I'm you got
a prom I have a younger brother and
anybody I just automatically think of my
brother so I have a younger brother I
adore him it's 24 so you can't be
younger than me I'm just like oh I just
see my brother and it's like oh look
would not date my brother yeah you don't
have to date your brother just because
he's 21 20 but my friends say I'm
mentally 25 Ruffa he'll you're you're
done this is a nuke Oh God 2400
certified yeah I'm good dialogue bye
everyone
what
[Music]
you put all these standards and no one's
left that's hilarious 20 guys and none
of them is qualified then maybe I'll
just point fingers here at Harlan but
there's not that many fingers to point
it wait what does I say there's not that
many people appointed I thought there
would be maybe four guys left she looks
like a really scary teacher that's what
I know I'm just judging for my scene I'm
sure Keith's lovely she's just a bass
but no I'm scared man but there were
none Oh today I learned that uh my
criteria is not I guess you see as I
thought it was but I'm okay with that
because you'll never meet that anyone
don't like these are values and things
that I don't want to bend and change
right now so I used to I don't get that
I don't get that you're either like
someone or you don't it shouldn't be
like you have to be this person and you
have to be like this because then you're
never gonna be satisfied like obviously
everyone is different in so many
different ways it's just ridiculous to
put this criteria you need to be if
there's any criteria what would I care
about like what would I I guess I would
want someone that would make me better
it's not like you have to be a certain
way but I want you to be a type of
energy that makes me want to improve
myself
I'm surrounded by someone that hates
everything and it's really lazy and all
that stuff you kind of drag get dragged
into that sphere I think those kind of
stuff matter or maybe it's on FISA from
you from TOC and they just want all your
money and yeah I don't know I really
beat myself up in my past relationships
after they ended cuz I felt like I
wasn't good enough but I think I'm at a
place in my life right now where I know
what I want and there's nothing wrong
with having these standards
you shouldn't have to bend your values
and what you want to please somebody
else I like you don't like you
it sounds good if she started off with
that like yeah I have values and a bad
past relationship so I don't want to
bend then them based on someone else
okay on paper that sounds nice but you
have to be this tall yeah I can't be
you're good to me
you can't be this you can't be that it's
like oh god the boys should remove her
from the group chat and become friends I
agree I second that 100%
it wasn't rude it was honest got him/her
who likes to dance someone I'm black did
they write that what the one month
younger than me is that really she's 25
like they could be the hottest person in
the room and if they tell me they're
even a month younger than me oh she did
say that even a month younger okay so
whoever took the girls you are play that
game now who was ever into boys you get
to play the game as well here we have 20
versus one speed-dating twenty girls
this main the the video is already
longer so I assume some some girls
actually made it past this time I'll say
- he looks like that comedian John
Mulaney isn't he a little bit Asian John
Mulaney it's John Mulaney Asian no he's
not hey I guess
I'll throw a number out if it's your
hook then hey that's my wife already so
it's gone I don't get the whole ticket
of photo when you're right there but hey
I guess help instead of a Hello I just
put hope
well typos didn't stop the other girl
Oh girls be thirsty damn
okay I mean that's why they're there no
I don't why would you go out on that why
you even asked that question I think I
definitely prefer girls who have been in
a relationship before or at least maybe
a long-term relationship because they
really kind of know what it's like to be
in relationship and starting something
new with somebody who's never had that
is a lot harder that's a weird one six
months is not that long damn somebody
say no they've never been in a six
mother really to say damn
yeah probably if someone's like 24 25
and never had more than six months I'd
probably be like yeah guess I'm part of
the problem let's see this man's emojis
we got the eggplant nice we got their
electrical plug nice the hook side waves
nice Japanese flag knives he's a weap I
get it cool I'll date him
oh wait he is Japanese isn't he's
brought yeah what was his name it
sounded Japanese na na kind of leaves
clickbait in the bedroom is always fun
for me that sounds like I'm Christian
Grey nothing too crazy I don't like like
things getting boring I just like
positions
brah my man you gotta be specific at
least at least the other girl looks like
feet choking all right at least I should
respect honesty now my mind is like
alright what the hell does this guy want
why does it bother me I don't care if
you're asking if I'll suck your toes
sure I'll try anything once
Lily no one asked that you you
understand it's about any toe sucking
Lily oh yeah this is online land consent
I think this new wise I have zero
preference I
and I'm not the racist did I mention
that I find everyone equal I think I
don't even see skin I see only muscles
and blood veins really it's just who I
am I'm kind of superior in that sense
definitely prefer girls who are either a
couple inches taller than me or shorter
I don't mind it when it goes a little
bit taller than me but if it's over like
two inches maybe what a difference in
the height preference conversion rate
one inch equals two point fifty to four
centimeters
okay so I'll just do red with two point
fifty four times big baby like white
I'll just do that in my head I guess
they have a phone Felix okay I'm sorry I
don't like you and girls believe in
horoscopes all the girls are out I take
it back in this all girls like horoscope
come on yes I'm making that general
assumption and a half the population but
it is true and tell me if I'm right
because he feels someone's like oh I'm a
Libra
I don't think click the moons aren't
aligned for this this month so we can't
really you know get yeah horoscope I you
know what I'll I'll rather listen to
horoscopes and then dreams fine
just don't tell me about your dream
don't care horoscopes can be interesting
even though I'm I'm not a fan
if you genuinely believe see so the
exams definitely have some truth but no
way I live life from horoscope that no
one does same it's actually fun it see
they're all into it look they're all
interesting yeah they're fun but they
all stayed huh oh
hypocrisy meth much huh saying thanks to
man up above but don't believe horoscope
I like girls does that say about society
my career of Arts so people who are
already down that path when we started
dating with studying arts they know
anything within that field career-wise
as something I kind of prefer the other
girl now and the other episodes at least
she's so straightforward this is so big
like do you like art yeah yeah I guess I
do talk about you know I can't talk
about accounting no one talks about
accounting every heard someone just
randomly bring up accounting as a
conversation no no one for your lines
within my interests within the arts
whether that be music physical painting
acting camera whatever no I just want to
talk about accounting what's your
problem
Oh they've one to work in the artisan in
future now he changed those kind of art
career alright you can love the arts see
he's making it's like oh please stay
actually I'm not drawing a line
come on dude
mr. Burton white like she's sending a
photo
Aloha Tanner's got it there are teas so
a lot of them made at this time huh oh
god I thought that hair was part of her
hair but shirt I'm so confusing was I
the only one who's smiling I was
surprised at how many people had not
been in a long-term relationship maybe I
was too specific on my my dates but
that's kind of interesting just like you
know from the get-go
yeah I guess I guess the everyone's true
colors comes out as time passes I guess
getting the few preferences out first is
kind of nice but I can't really see
that's the point it's not gonna matter
if you like someone anyway only muscle
and flesh don't really care
damn very good episode subscribe to
Yubel a big shout outs I enjoy that a
lot if you did as well subscribe comment
like and do all that you stand there I
see you tomorrow hey door so cs3
how many bro we say so horny I'm not
really oh yeah I'm recording cool salute
the Spillane clicking